good morning it's friday so i just
dropped alice off and i said hey alice
do you mind if i wear this mask while i
drop you off and she said
um maybe you could wear it later i mean
there's embarrassing your kids and then
there's
embarrassing your kids this has been one
of the most popular pizzamas items along
with this uh
three john pizza moon shirt and i just i
just hope everyone knows what they're
getting into
i can't do it anymore okay i gotta go
vote but also we need to talk about the
racks guy
it is a phenomenally beautiful day in
indianapolis by the way
so first thing i just want to
acknowledge that immediately after i
made a video about why we're not trying
to maximize views on vlogbrothers
anymore you made a video that went to
the front page of reddit and got lots
and lots of views
so hank racks is a restaurant that
hosted a huge percentage of our
childhood like it
is so significant to my childhood that
even now
i can close my eyes and picture the
exact layout of a
well i mean that seems like an
overreaction from my perspective
i can close my eyes and picture the
exact
layout of a rack's restaurant like every
rack had this weird
quasi-green house that went off the side
of it where you could like
sit and feel like you were sort of
outside and even though there are only
like five racks restaurants left in
america there are still a lot of those
buildings it reminds me of one of my
favorite onion headlines you can tell
that local bank used to be a pizza hut
well i can tell when a restaurant used
to be a racks
so when we were growing up in orlando in
the 1980s if you sat in that
greenhouse part of our local racks you
could see a house
and in that house lived a person who we
called
the racks guy and this house had all
these hand-painted signs on the fence
around it about how like the government
was tyranny but also like really weird
conspiracy theories about like lizard
people and stuff and there was like an
upside down flag hanging from the
flagpole and it
just did not look like the rest of
orlando and the reason you and i have
had so many conversations about the rax
guy in the last 10 years is that he was
like the first twitter user he would
post
relatively short observations to his
fence and also even though i knew that
wizard people didn't run the government
the rax guy's world view
still like affected me hold on i gotta
go vote
all right i have voted i even got a
sticker hey if you're eligible to vote
in the united states i really hope that
you
will and that you make a plan to vote if
you need an accountability buddy to help
make sure that you
execute your voting plan i also
recommend doing that i have an
accountability buddy it's my best friend
chris i just texted him to let him know
that i voted but right about the racks
guys so hank the very first
obsessive experience i can remember
having is this worry
that everyone else on earth wasn't a
real person
in the way i was that like they were
these uh aliens
and they had very fancy human costumes
that they wore when i was around and
then when i wasn't around they went back
to being aliens
this worry really tortured me when i was
a kid
for years now i want to be clear that
the rax guy did not cause me to have ocd
i was going to have it anyway but the
rax guy
did influence the particular worry that
ended up taking over my life when i was
seven and eight years old
that's it that's the video our
information feeds shape us
my information feed shaped me as a kid
in 1985 going to racks on special
occasions
and my information feed shapes me today
what you do with your attention
is in the end what you do with your life
and so i gotta be careful what i pay
attention to
because the stuff that's the loudest and
the most outrageous
is for me at least also often the stuff
of nightmares
all that noted i hope the rax guy is
doing all right he's probably crushing
it on the social internet actually
there's never been a better time for
racks guys
hank i'll see you on monday